[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers
guten Abend ihnen allen Frieden schaffen
ohne Waffen war mal ein hoffnungsvolles
Motto das wurde dann realpolitisch
abgewandelt in Frieden schaffen mit
immer weniger Waffen in Zeiten sind
vorbei gegen gnadenlose militärische
Aggression helfen keine warmen Worte die
Ukraine brauchen neue Waffen und das
schnell die NATO ein klares Bekenntnis
das ist die Haltung die heute auf dem
Parteitag der Grünen eine sehr große
Mehrheit bekam da reiben sich manche
Beobachter die Augen die Parteispitze
reibt sich die Hände Thomas Reichert
berichtet
die Grenzen der Grünen Außenpolitik
beginnen schon vor dem parteitagsgebäude
mit blutroten Handflächen protestieren
exilianer gegen die Gewalt des
müller-regimes und gegen die in ihren
Augen zu schwache Reaktion Deutschlands
wir sind schon enttäuscht wir erwarten
dass jetzt nicht gehandelt wird wir
wissen nicht was die Menschen im Iran
noch tun müssen was wir im Exil noch tun
müssen damit endlich Bewegung ins Spiel
kommt drinnen ist die Welt eine etwas
andere die Grünen sind nachhaltig stolz
auf sich selbst und auf ihr Mitgefühl
keine Frau im Iran keine Frau Ukraine
keine Frau nach kleines hat oder ist
Saudi-Arabien das rennt Zweifel dass wir
an ihrer Seite stehen dass wir Sie nicht
alleine lassen werden und das sind
mündlich sollten die Grünen der Applaus
überdeckt ein Grundproblem grüner
Außenpolitik sie stößt überall an ihre
Grenzen wegen Russlands Angriffskrieg
der Energiekrise und der SPD ein
Saudi-Arabien etwa liefert die
Bundesregierung Kampfjets und Munition
eine Ausnahme sagen die Grünen wegen
Vorverträgen umgekehrt soll es
Energielieferungen geben aus den
Golfstaaten
geht es um die Energieversorgung ist die
Unterdrückung und Verfolgung von Frauen
und Queen Menschen in Ländern wie
Saudi-Arabien und der Katar plötzlich
kein Thema mehr noch eine Grenze die
Ukraine mit großer Mehrheit stimmt die
Grünen für die Lieferung weiterer Waffen
nur wenige halten aus Protest die alten
Plakate der 80er Jahre hoch warnen vor
einem möglichen Atomkrieg die
Unterstützung der Ukraine geht in der
Partei weiter es in der Koalition wo ein
roter Kanzler eine grüne Außenministerin
bremst die mehr und schneller Waffen
liefern würde
wir haben diese Waffenlieferungen nicht
beschlossen obwohl wie eine
menschenrechtspartei und Friedenspartei
sind sondern weil wir eine
menschenrechts- und friedensvorteil sind
deswegen verwundert es auch nicht viele
dass wir ausgerechnet als grüne auch im
Baltikum in Polen eben ein großes
Vertrauen haben dass wir uns dafür
einsetzen die Ukraine weiter zu
unterstützen und dann noch diese Grenze
die China-Politik Werte basiert sagen
die Grünen sollte sie gegenüber hier
sein
handelsbasierter kannst du euch heute
demnächst mit wirtschaftsposten nach
Peking bin die Grünen sind sauer denn
der Box Außenministerium schreibt gerade
an einer china-strategie die kritisch
werden soll was ich nicht für akzeptabel
halten würde wäre wenn das Kanzleramt so
tut als würden jetzt vom Kanzleramt aus
die Blöcke eingehauen und die
China-Politik muss ich dann danach
richten was das Kanzleramt für richtig
hält so kann die Einigkeit des
Parteitags nicht überdecken dass die
grüne Werte basierte Außenpolitik gerade
landet in einer rauen Wirklichkeit
es ist noch nicht klar wer hinter dem
Anschlag auf die Gaspipelines in der
Ostsee steckt hinter der Sabotageaktion
gegen die Deutsche Bahn da warnen die
Sicherheitsbehörden von neuen steigenden
Risiken ein Blackout also ein kompletter
Stromausfall mit allem was da dranhängt
sei ein realistisches Szenario sagt der
Deutsche Städtetag das BKA mahnt die
Betreiber von Energieanlagen aktuell zu
äußerster Vorsicht wie schwer das in der
Praxis umzusetzen ist zeigt jetzt Hannah
Hebestreit am Beispiel Norwegen das Land
das für uns in Sachen Öl und Gas immer
mehr zu einer Art Rettungsanker wird
wo diese Schafe friedliche Lagern
befürchten Norwegens Behörden
Sabotageaktionen auf Europas
Erdgasversorgung dieser Anlage in
korschtüll verarbeitet Erdgas aus der
Nordsee das von hier durch Pipelines
auch nach Deutschland fließt seit
einigen Tagen sichern bewaffnete
Reservisten diesen Industriekomplex
normalerweise helfen wir bei Erdrutschen
oder suchen vermisste das hier ist schon
eine ganz andere Sache ein sehr ernster
Auftrag da macht man sich schon seine
Gedanken was ist eigentlich bedeutet
hier aufzupassen
damit hat der Krieg in der Ukraine
Norwegens Zivilgesellschaft erreicht
Irland arbeitet eigentlich mit
Jugendlichen jetzt schützt der
27-Jährige kritische Infrastruktur
messem
Militär um im Wald Krieg zu spielen auf
so etwas hier sind wir vorbereitet es
gab Bob Dreck
Anlagen zur Gas- und Stromversorgung an
Land lassen sich relativ gut sichern um
das Netz an Pipelines und Bohrinsel in
der Nordsee sorgt sich der
gasnetzbetreiber gasco er ist
verantwortlich für die Sicherheit von
vielen tausend leitungskilometern
zwischen Norwegen und seinen Gaskunden
im restlichen
Europas haben auch wir die
Sicherheitsmaßnahmen hochgefahren und
wir haben sie noch einmal verschärft
nachdem was kürzlich in der Ostsee
passiert ist
nach der mutmaßlichen Sabotage an den
nordstream Pipelines hat Norwegen
zusätzliches Militär in die Nordsee
entsandt zum Schutz vor Attacken auf
seine Infrastruktur
IWA Strömen von der norwegischen
seekriegsschule in Bergen hält es für
durchaus wahrscheinlich das Russland
hier Aktionen plant von neugierter
Norwegen ist zu einem geostrategischen
Hotspot geworden wir sind wohl das
wichtigste Ziel in dieser Art von
Grauzonen Kriegsführung in Europa weil
wir so stark zur europäischen
Energieversorgung beitragen vor allem
auf der Nordsee
Norwegen und seine Nato-Partner bemühen
sich deshalb auf der Nordsee frühzeitig
Vorbereitungen von möglichen
Sabotageakten zu erkennen
Rostock
nämlich groß herauszubekommen Werder
etwas plant und wenn wir mit Sicherheit
sagen können dass das die Russen sind
wäre das eine wirksame Waffe gegen einen
solchen Angriff weil wir dann ein
offener Kriegsakt gegen die NATO wäre
die europäische Energieversorgung
scheint also zur Waffe im Ukraine Krieg
zu werden Ihre Sicherheit hängt auch
davon ab wie gut Norwegen auf seine
kritische Infrastruktur achtet auch dort
wo die Schafe ganz friedlich grasen
ja während Skandinavien aufgeschreckt
ist und sich bemüht Angriffe zu
verhindern erlebt die Ukraine jeden Tag
neu was passiert wenn eine fremde Armee
es eben auf die eigene Energieversorgung
abgesehen hat Katrin Eugendorf ist
unsere Reporterin in Kiew guten Abend
Katrin wie ist die aktuelle Lage was ist
da heute passiert
ja guten Abend Christian es hat so wie
gestern auch heute wieder Angriffe auch
wieder auf Kiew gegeben zwar nur in die
Umgebung von Kiew nicht direkt hier ins
Zentrum aber so wie es aussieht ist
wieder gezielt ein Stromversorger
getroffen worden die ukrainische
Regierung hält sich relativ zurück was
die genauen Angaben über den Umfang der
getroffenen Ziele jetzt angeht
wahrscheinlich auch um der russischen
Seite nicht unnötig viel Informationen
zu liefern aber ganz klar ist dass
dieser Krieg um die kritische
Infrastruktur den Putin ja schon seit
Tagen geführt hat und der am Montag
sicherlich seinen deutlichen Höhepunkt
erlebt hat weiter fortgeführt wird
Putins Ziel ist ganz klar und dass der
russischen Armee in der Ukraine dafür zu
sorgen dass die Energieversorgung
deutlich getroffen wird das ist
natürlich vor allem besonders brisant
mit dem einsetzenden Winter und man kann
sehen dass das im Moment wirklich
flächendeckend im ganzen Land passiert
die Regierung geht mittlerweile davon
aus dass ein Drittel der kritischen
Infrastruktur mittlerweile in
Mitleidenschaft gekommen ist und man
kommt gar nicht mehr so schnell nach
dass alles wieder zu reparieren und
aufzubauen ja wie es vernichtet wird
Katrin vielen Dank wir bleiben noch
einen Moment bei dir und zeigen jetzt
was dort zurück bleibt wo die russische
Armee den Rückzug antritt bzw antreten
muss es ist ein fürchterlicher Anblick
eine Spur der Zerstörung haben die
russischen Soldaten hinterlassen auf den
Straßen in den Wäldern und Orten im
Osten von hakiff und es sind nicht nur
ihre Panzer ihre Munition Uniformen und
Essensreste auch ihre Toten ließen sie
zurück
ukrainische freiwillige Bergen nun die
die kamen um ihr Land zu überfallen
Datum Name und Fundort haben sie notiert
Leichnam Nummer 101 steht auf dem
Plastiksack
diese Leichen sollen nach Hause
zurückkehren damit die Menschen die sie
hierhin geschickt haben die Folgen sehen
dass sie ihnen die Zukunft genommen
haben
wir treffen die metrooperazzov der
Presseoffizier der Nationalgarde will
uns zeigen wie die russischen Soldaten
den Bahnhof von kasachchanopan
hinterlassen haben den sie als
Stabstelle genutzt hatten
fällt Telefone und Berge von kleinen
Briefen russischer Schulkinder
du bist mein Soldat mein Held ich danke
dem Himmel für deine schönen Augen und
deine Freundlichkeit und dafür dass ich
dich liebe Julia 8 Jahre alt
die Post aus der Heimat von Kindern die
gerade schreiben lernen säckeweise wurde
sie hingeschickt
sie erziehen die Kinder schon von der
zweiten Klasse wie wir sehen das sind
Kinder im Alter von sieben Jahren und
der Junge denkt dass die Soldaten ihre
Pflicht erfüllen diese Kinder wachsen
heran und von Kindheit wissen sie dass
der Ukrainer der Feind ist
überall ein ähnliches Bild vor allem in
Wohnvierteln hinterlassen die Russen
gefährliche Reste von Munition sogar
Minen und unbeschreibliches Chaos
führt mitriobra Zoff und seine Soldaten
Zeugen die Spuren davon dass kaum
Disziplin unter Putins Truppen herrscht
das sind Spielkarten und Sachen zum
Rauchen von Cannabis das hier wird damit
gefüllt und dann hier reingetan so haben
sie sich amüsiert
das alles so sind sie überzeugt deutet
darauf hin dass Putin Soldaten ihnen
unterlegen sind und das Ziel ihr Land zu
befreien erreichbar ist
und dann dramatische Nachrichten heute
aus Iran Feuer im berüchtigten in Wien
Gefängnis von Teheran in dem das Regime
gegen dass sie in irania seit Wochen
protestieren viele politische Gefangene
festhält Hannah du hast das was wir im
Moment dazu wissen ja über das Feuer im
wigen Medien überein
stimmend in den sozialen Netzwerken
zahlreiche Videos des Brands darin sind
auch Schüsse zu hören die staatliche
Nachrichtenagentur irner zitierte einen
Sicherheitsbeamten der von Unruhen
sprach die nun beendet sein die genauen
Hintergründe sind noch unklar
nach der schweren Explosion in einem
Kohlebergwerk im Norden der Türkei ist
die Zahl der Toten auf 41 gestiegen das
erklärte der türkische Präsident Erdogan
bei einem Besuch des Unglücksorts die
Explosion ereignete sich in etwa 300
Metern Tiefe die genaue Ursache ist noch
nicht bekannt wegen mangelhafter
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen kommt es immer
wieder zu schweren Grubenunglücken in
der Türkei
Bundeskanzler Scholz hat sich für eine
deutliche Erweiterung der Europäischen
Union ausgesprochen auf dem Kongress der
Sozialdemokratischen Partei Europas
sagte er eine EU mit 27 30 36 Staaten
könne ihr Gewicht in der Welt noch
stärker zur Geltung bringen gleichzeitig
forderte Scholz die schrittweise
Abschaffung des Prinzips der
Einstimmigkeit für Entscheidungen in der
Außen-
mit Blick auf die steigenden
corona-infektionszahlen hat der Chef der
Deutschen Krankenhausgesellschaft Gas
eine Wiedereinführung der maskenpflicht
in Innenräumen gefordert in den meisten
Kliniken sei mittlerweile kein
Normalbetrieb mehr möglich planbare
Operationen und Behandlungen würden
verschoben sagte Gast der Passauer Neuen
Presse
ein schwerer Sturm hat auf der
griechischen Insel Kreta für
Überschwemmungen gesorgt dabei kam laut
Feuerwehr ein Mann ums Leben dessen Auto
von den Wassermassen mitgerissen wurde
eine Frau werde noch vermisst betroffen
war auch der internationale Flughafen in
Heraklion der zeitweise geschlossen
werden musste nun die Lottozahlen von
diesem Samstag die lauten 11 29 32 37 43
48 Superzahl 7 alle Angaben wie immer
ohne Gewähr
fehlt noch der Blick auf die
wetteraussichten vom Saarland bis nach
Sachsen regnet es morgen zeitweise und
auch an der Nordsee gibt es Schauer
sonst ist es freundlich im Norden werden
16 bis 21 Grad erreicht im Süden 20 bis
25 Grad mit bis zu 26 Grad wird der
Montag noch etwas wärmer im Nordwesten
regnet es der Dienstag wird allgemein
unbeständig der Mittwoch wieder
freundlicher aber kühler
Wahnsinn 26 Grad habe ich da gerade
gehört im Oktober das muss man mal
wieder dazu sagen so wir sind morgen
wieder für Sie da und zwar sehr gerne
für heute bedanken wir uns alle dass Sie
bei uns waren und wünschen Ihnen noch
einen angenehmen Abend
[Musik]